You can catch a big river. You can make one piece of clothing with this
one animal.
Ito has a good face.Is he going to leave it and use it or still eat it?
So
[music] The
eyeballs don't taste like boiled octopus
You can suck it Sugimoto a
ok
Sugimoto
Fujimino Sugimoto or Roco
Why is that
I'm the 4th division
Eh,
did I warn you?
Be careful, the platoon I'm in is someone else's attention, and even though I've been told that since my state, it doesn't matter. The 7th Division certainly has 20,000 people.
I got it right from the scars on my face It's like meeting a war hero in a place like this There's no such thing
as
death It's just that I had it Come on
, why are you with these guys
?  says so, can you believe it?